[Music]
it's funny because i've heard you in
interviews say that you first how tall
are you you are 7-1 you are 7-1 that you
have a little guy mentality what do you
mean by that
well growing up i hung out with a lot of
little guys just like now i'm with a lot
of little guys
i should do a lot of little guy things
so
uh
one day
i went to the uh
look for pots of gold
live under a toadstool yeah so uh
you know when i first came from from
from uh baton rouge beverly hills you
see all the fancy cars come by so one
day i see a ferrari come by i was like i
want one of those guys
so i went to the thing and the guy was
like you're too big you know i hate
those words you're too big yeah i was
like i'm too big yeah so one of the guys
was like well maybe you got to buy two
and put you know cut one and a half put
them together i was like you know what
maybe i will i'll take that one in that
one and i got a ferrari wait you built a
ferrari where you could
you cut them apart yes and then you made
like a giant stretch ferrari yes
that's professionals do this right you
didn't do it yourself no i didn't do he
broke it in half
am i right uh shaq i have to
congratulate you getting your doctorate
is that right yes
[Applause]
what are you getting your doctorate in
what's your dissertation on do you want
the regular voice or the doctoral voice
i would like the doctoral voice please
well uh my doctorate is in hrd
organizational leadership things like
that uh the dissertation is the duality
of humor and seriousness in leadership
styles i'm anxious to see which leader
is more effective the humorous leader or
the serious leader and what have your
findings been professor well i found
that a modulation process occurs
that you're not either either all
humorous or all serious that modulation
process occurs when certain situations
arise this is fantastic
[Applause]
when the actual ceremony takes place are
you going to be addressed then as dr
o'neal or still a shack no i'm thinking
about getting rid of the name shaq and
that happened you're gonna retire the
name yes yes
don't anger him
yes
uh so so are you going to get rid of
shaq for everybody or just because kids
know you as shaq no the kids can call me
shaq but you two dr o'neill all right
let's practice
yes dr o'neill yes do you think do you
think dr j will be threatened
he worked hard for that all right all
right i'll try uh uh hey jack what's up
jack
you who [ __ ] dr o'neal hello
all right nice to see you
nice to see you now dr o'neal uh
recently uh
not yet oh okay shaq
uh not long ago you helped charles
barkley celebrate his 49th birthday and
you guys are friends and you took him to
an italian restaurant
and uh this picture leaked out what's
going on here
whoa what the hell
i get that looks like again like you
took nine meatballs and put them
together to make a super meat ball well
this restaurant buca de peppa you know
they serve big servings yeah you know
charles is on the weight watchers thing
so i'm allowed to eat what i want to eat
so i was all in his face like
that
and he couldn't eat it even though his
slogan is you can still keep your
meatballs yeah so i got out like the
real big meatball that's his slogan
i i guess you should have got for his
birthday get him a new slogan